>>>> Announcer: "GAME OF
THRONES," THE FINAL SEASON.
ONLY SIX EPISODES REMAIN UNTIL
WE SAY GOODBYE TO HBO'S
THRILLING SAGA.
BUT THE JOURNEY CONTINUES WITH
PREQUELS, SEQUELS, AND SPINOFFS.
LIKE "CASTLE BLACK," A SEX,
MOODY DRAMA ABOUT FORBIDDEN
LOVE.
>> HEY.
>> YOU CAME.
>> YEAH.
AND YOU PROMISED THAT WHEN
WINTER CAME YOU WOULD TELL YOUR
FRIENDS ABOUT ME, ABOUT US.
WINTER IS HERE, JON.
>> IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE.
YOU'RE DEAD.
>> YOU WERE DEAD TOO.
>> THAT WAS DIFFERENT AND YOU
KNOW IT.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
STOP.
STOP THAT.
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU WANT, ISN'T
IT?
COME TAKE IT.
>>> AND CHECK OUT EVERYONE'S
FAVORITE ASSASSIN IN CARTOON
FORM.
IT'S ARYA.
>> HEY, ARYA, ARE YOU GOING TO
THE DANCE WITH THE FACELESS MAN?
>> A GIRL IS GOING WITH HER
FRIENDS.
>> AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
LAUGHS, YOU'LL LOVE SAM AND
GILLY IN "THE QUEEN OF KING'S
LANDING."
>> SAM, WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
KITCHEN?
WERE WE ATTACKED BY THE FREE
FOLK?
>> EVEN WORSE.
I TRIED TO MAKE DINNER.
>> PLUS IT'S GOING TO BE A GAME
OF CROSSOVERS WITH SHOWS LIKE
CERSEI AND THE CITY, THE
MARVELOUS MRS. MELLISANDRE, AND
DRAGONS AREN'T THE ONLY ONES
SPITTING FIRE ON.
>> THIS WHITE BITCH KNOW HE
CAN'T STOP ME.
YO, WHY Y'ALL GOT ME OUT HERE
BATTLING BOOTLEG KING JOFFREY?
>> AND OVER ON HBO KIDS, WE GOT
FAMILY FRIENDLY SHOWS LIKE
HODOR'S HOUSE.
>> HODOR!
>> AND FRANCHISES COLLIDE IN OUR
NEW PROCEDURAL, "GOT SVU."
>> YOU TELL ME SOME SICK SON OF
A BITCH CUT HIS THING OFF,
GOUGED A MAN'S EYES OUT AND FED
HIM HIS OWN EYES?
>> DING DING.
>> THEN GOT BUSY IN THE HOLES
WHERE HIS EYES USED TO BE?
>> CIRCLE GETS THE SQUARE.
>> GAME OF THRONES.
WE'RE GOING FULL "STAR WARS" ON
THIS.